the political world is still trying to
understand why Fox would fire its
highest rated host the highest rated
host in the history of cable news at the
height of his powers
several theories are swirling some have
said it's because of a recent defamation
lawsuit related to the 2020 election but
that theory Falls flat when you remember
that plenty of other Fox hosts went way
further than Tucker on Election fraud
claims and they still have their jobs
another theory is that Tucker just chose
to leave that one Falls flat when you
remember that he signed off his Friday
show telling viewers that he'd be back
on Monday now
Vanity Fair as a third Theory
the theory is that Tucker was fired for
a speech he gave at the Heritage
Foundation over the weekend
maybe we should all take just like 10
minutes a day to say a prayer about it
I'm serious like why not
and I'm saying that to you not as some
kind of evangelist I'm literally saying
that to you as an Episcopalian the
Samaritans of our time I'm coming to you
from the most humble and lowly
theological position you can I'm
literally an Episcopalian okay
and even I have concluded it might be
worth taking just 10 minutes out of your
busy schedule to say a prayer for the
future and I hope you will
the whole speech was excellent I was not
able to attend that dinner because I was
already booked to speak at another
conservative gathering in Colorado that
night I do wish I could have made it to
the dinner though it turns out that
Heritage Foundation dinner might have
been one of the most consequential in
the history of conservative media
according to Vanity Fair the head honcho
over at News Corp didn't like Tucker's
religious recommendation a fox Source
reportedly told Vanity Fair quote that
stuff freaks Rupert out
I don't know what really motivated Fox
to fire Tucker of all the theories out
there this one is the most absurd
Episcopalian extremism
the jokes write themselves that's the
joke that Tucker made
as he gave his advice it's the craziest
motive you could think of
which is why it's also the most
convincing in this Fallen World
you can call for the slaughter of babies
the castration of children the wholesale
denial of Truth and you will be
celebrated as a wise man and a hero you
will be rewarded
but gently suggest that people humble
themselves and pray to God
the principalities and powers and
spiritual wickedness in high places that
you might have heard about the prince of
this world they don't like that so much
that's the sort of thing that can get
you taken off the air
and that's the sort of thing that proves
Tucker's point right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles we
all know about the big wireless cell
companies out there they lock you into
these horrendous contracts and if you
try to get out of them early they tack
on outrageous charges that is why I
would strongly recommend making the
switch to Pure Talk Wireless where there
are no hidden fees and no contracts and
no hassle I love pure talk I am so glad
that we got the Pure Talk service pure
talks U.S customer service team helps
their customers make the switch in as
little as 10 minutes makes it so that
you are even able to keep your phone
number if your talk has a range of
affordable cell phone plans to choose
from you can find it the perfect option
for your needs like unlimited talk text
and plenty of data for just thirty
dollars a month their 5G service is
super fast consistent and doesn't drop
calls you can get the same coverage
you're used to at half the rate you're
currently paying Pure Talk saves the
average family over 900 per year not
only will you save money you will also
get the satisfaction of knowing that
you're supporting a great American
company the city EO and chairman of pure
talk is a U.S military vet when you
become a Pure Talk customer you are
given the option to support America's
Warrior partnership which is an
organization that works to prevent
veteran suicide go to puretalk.com enter
promo code Knowles to save 50 off your
first month puretalk.com promo code
Knowles Canada wlas Pure Talk is simply
smarter Wireless at least one person is
celebrating I think a lot of the left is
celebrating right now but but one
leftist figure in particular AOC could
not be happier Tucker Carlson is out at
Fox News
couldn't have happened to a better guy
um
what I will say though is
while I'm very glad that the person that
was arguably responsible for the
some of the largest driving some of the
most amounts of death threats and
violent threats not just to my office
but to plenty of people across the
country I also kind of feel like
I'm like waiting for the cut scene at
the end of a Marvel movie after all the
credits have rolled and then you see
like the villains like hand
re-emerge out to glip grip over like the
end of a building or something
but
de-platforming works and it is important
and um
there you go good things can happen
so blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah D platforming
works that's her thesis
and putting all the blah blah blahs
aside and you just get to the central
thesis of her argument
she's right
d-platforming does work
the left knows that that's why the left
D platforms people and severely hampers
their ability to communicate
and to the right
some people on the right know that but
some people on the right engage in
magical thinking where they believe well
the more you suppress me the more you
censor me the more people will talk
about me it'll have an ironic it'll have
a paradoxical effect where actually if
you try to suppress my speech it'll just
go everywhere that isn't true
think of the major figures who were
kicked off of social media
they just kind of went away
big people in the media
de-platformed they just kind of went
away they were they may have maintained
a small power base but their reach was
greatly diminished this is true even of
Donald Trump
Donald Trump every thought that passed
through his head he would tweet out and
it dominated the news cycle for years
and years and years
then they booted him off of social media
and even Trump who had been a celebrity
for 40 years he had been the president
of the United States he
diminished he faded in the National
conversation
some people still talked about his
press releases and his
truth social posts but nowhere near the
kind of press coverage that you saw at
the height of his powers de-platforming
works
and conservatives should Embrace that
not the arbitrary or unjust kind of
de-platforming that the libs push where
you say oh he said a true thing we gotta
shut him up oh he said men aren't really
women we oh we gotta we gotta censor
that guy oh he said babies are actually
human beings oh we got to shut him up we
gotta stop him from saying that no
but we do support some kind of deep
platform we want we want to de-platform
drag queens in the elementary school
don't we okay so there we go we're
admitting that d-platforming works
we want to de-platform the leftists who
are making direct threats against
conservatives don't we okay
d-platforming works we want to
de-platform Maya kababi the author of
genderqueer which is gay porn in the
libraries for kids yeah okay D
platforming Works you're right it does
work aoc's got a point
now in the case of Tucker Carlson Miss
Tucker totally done no I hope I hope
he's got plenty of other outlets that
would be more than happy to platform him
I know daily wire certainly would
Jeremy pointed out uh when when Tucker
got the can at uh Fox he said listen I
assume Tucker's already got his own
plans but we are willing to break out a
comically sized uh cardboard Shack you
know if he's willing to come on over
here
but but D platforming certainly works
that was a really great clip I know I
agree if you want more of them you got
to subscribe ring that Bell hit that
like
Punk that horn I don't know whatever you
have to do subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time
foreign
[Music]